[Music]
why is it that
in the world of counter-strike it's the
operas who get all the recognition
it's all anyone talks about the no
scopes the clutches
the impossible flicks and with good
reason
they're nutty absurd unremittingly
hype the showstoppers of cs go
there is the world's best sniper
but what about your run-of-the-mill
riflers why is
that they never seem to get any credit
why is it that we tend to overlook our
everyday expendable anchors
entry fraggers and intel gatherers the
sprayers who don't always have the
luxury of being surgical
whose thankless job is to hold a sight
go in first
or support their stars by serving as
cannon fodder
the bread and butter blue collar working
class killers of
counter-strike those who aren't afforded
the sexiest hardware
[Music]
well with one exception of
look at course where they really
struggle
scream is this real it's down to a liege
twist has done some of the heavy lifting
two frags the time is on his side elite
hasn't got a single frag to show for
himself here on dust2
he's going to be pressured shot down
they're confusing
one versus three
the automat kalashnikov model of 1947
is a weapon that quite literally
requires no introduction
developed in the soviet union in the
aftermath of the second world war it has
spent seven
decades as the single most popular and
widely adopted rifle
in the world a weapon all fighters love
an elegantly simple nine-pound
amalgamation of forged steel and plywood
it doesn't break jam or overheat it will
shoot whether it's covered in mud or
filled with sand
it's so easy even a child can use it and
they do
needless to say it isn't the fanciest of
firearms
it isn't the most accurate up-to-date
and doesn't always boast the sleekest
features
but it is sure as [ __ ] the most robust
now bull will test the ak-47 said to be
more reliable
buying a hole wow
yes two
as europe is gone but the result is good
cool so the ak-47 has actually passed
this horrible test with flying colours
given that the ak has long been a staple
of the so-called irregular
or insurgent militias across the globe
it seemed like a no-brainer to make it
the flagship shooting iron of the
terrorist force in the scrappy
underground soon-to-be esports sensation
that was
counter-strike hey guys i'm hidden today
i'm going to teach you the terrorist
weapons the ak-47
and the glock similar to its real-life
counterpart the 1.6 ak was
loud and abrasive and had enough recoil
that it pretty much required a pilot's
license
to control to learn the recoil with the
ak-47
simply do like this stand towards the
wall and hold the mouse button down
don't drag it down for recoil as you can
see it goes up
right then left again so if you learn it
you duck spray towards the same distance
as you can see all the same bullets in
the same area with atlanta kill on the
ct here
it was also the most vital and versatile
weapon in the game
the thing around which the entire
attacker defender dichotomy was balanced
the one gun that you had to learn
regardless of position
preference or playstyle
the ak was cheap powerful effective at
any range
and adaptable you could tap with it
deliver surgical
bursts or provided you'd mastered its
signature t-spray patterns
hold left-click to your heart's content
of course what
really set the ak apart was the fact
that it could inflict a one
shot headshot through armor from
anywhere on the map
and that one little detail changed
everything
so the main thing the main uniqueness
this power brings to like your
arsenal is the fact that you can control
a tap or a spray and only really need to
take one bullet to your enemy's head to
get the frag
so it's like if you're gonna focus on
tapping you could do six to eight bullet
tap sprees if you're going to focus on
spraying
you can spray your whole clip but you
can be moving a lot as well just because
it's very effective and you only need
that one bullet
it meant that if wheel did properly the
ak was the best gun
in the game even the op with its hefty
price
tag lengthy reload time and struggles at
a close range
wasn't as dynamically destructive as
this shoddy wooden miracle worker
if your aim was filthy enough and you
had an ak-47
you could do anything
but the truly remarkable thing about the
ak is that
just like its real steel original it
never ever
changed for over 10 years across four
different iterations of counter strike
this t-side terror had remained the
franchise's fixed point
the be-all and end-all of rifles
counter-strike
simply wasn't counter-strike without it
many players
including myself consider the ak-47 to
be the best
weapon in the game to make things even
better the ak-47 is nearly perfectly
accurate on its first
shot this means that with the proper
application of skill
a player with an ak-47 is nearly
unstoppable
from 1.6 to source to condition zero to
global offensive the ak was essentially
the most static thing
in cs having never been subjected to any
substantial rework
in fact pretty much the only thing that
did change was the recoil
single clicks are still very accurate so
tapping the gun when shooting far range
is much more appropriate rather than
spraying
you can see here though that the third
bullet in a burst is when the recoil
really starts to take over and the
recoil is
really quite strong because of this kick
on the third bullet it's a lot easier to
shoot bursts packed with two bullets
rather than with three or four whereas
1.6 was considered a tapper's game and
source was a full-blown
run and gun nightmare cs go essentially
became a marriage of the two
gradually recoil was reworked so that it
was more chaotic and harder to control
but more consistent and easier to
predict here's what the uncontrolled
spray pattern looks like
very familiar to previous versions of
counter-strike it still has that typical
up motion
followed by going left and right the
result was that
over time global offensive began to
breed and foster a new species of rifler
strict scrupulous players who'd become
so intimately familiar with the game's
recoil patterns
that they could conduct open heart
surgery with a kalashnikov
dennis loves to play aggressive on amane
oh my god the costume nico nice shot
don't pay attention oh my god nico three
make it four all headshots
under shadow a nice break from him but
it's gonna be all down the street
oh my god what the [ __ ]
[Music]
pardon my french i apologize but that
spray transfer was
probably the most insane spray transfer
i've ever seen
and while there were still those who
fancied themselves single shot savants
such as the belgian bully scream who'd
sparked a ton
of talk about his so-called one taps
especially because the ct side is their
better side it's their t-side where they
really struggle
scream is this real
the thing that tended to characterize
csgo's sickest riflers was their ability
to oscillate between
semi and fully automatic ownage a
standout in this respect was french
phenom
shocks who became renowned for his
ability to frag out with the ak at
any frequency and he has been top
fragging for a very long time here on
dust two
it's on shot [ __ ] at 103 to try and keep
it alive otherwise we'll go to a fifth
map in the grand finals
shocks tabs out one that's a deadly kill
goes for the second and he's moving
closer
looking for the quad clutch here fnx the
last man alive he's gonna tap the bomb
once
you've got to be kidding he takes the
quad kill because even though the vast
majority of the game's biggest
superstars were snipers
there did exist a special sect of
aimbots like elish
nico and electronic who'd managed to
turn spraying into an
art form maestros who were so cracked
they didn't need to op and for experts
such as these
the go-to instrument was never not the
ak
it was the gold standard when it came to
counter-strike gats
you bought it as a t and you took every
opportunity to pick one up on
ct that's how it had always been that's
how it would always be
i pressed to the scope it's down to a
liege twist has done some of the heavy
lifting two frags the time is on his
side elite hasn't got a single frag to
show for himself here on dust two
but he's gonna be pressured needed shot
that they're defusing
one versus three that's what they needed
that's what new york wants to see
because at the end of the day great cs
go rosters
weren't built on fancy op flicks or
once-in-a-lifetime deagle aces
they were built on honest everyday
executes
this could be the ticket for astralis
these grenades could do
all of the work for them three of them
going over the wall one on exist
one on crims everybody's catching fire
twist goes down and there it is
they throws it right out two on four
jw and brolan left everywhere is a
crossfire
you are gonna have to spend days looking
for these remaining players
and they know it as well jw trying to
sneak on in
what a match this is jw goes down and
it's 15 15
over time here at the semifinals whether
it was nip
fanatic sk luminosity or freaking
astralis literally every great dynasty
in the history of cs go
had built their legacy on exacting
efficient rifling that relied on the
unquestionable
unfailing superiority of the ak
when they have ak in the hands and the
enemy has a m4
uh you don't have to be afraid of taking
any wheels
like you have an ak you are the you are
picking him
it's quite hard to kill a t just running
out
faking again the hand for a city you can
just hold the angle it can be anybody to
have
like a amazing aim but it's just it's
every time it's hard when
that he just pushes swing like higher
picks you
out of a corner and trying to kill you
and if there's another player behind
it's just kind of impossible to keep one
of them and don't die
to supplant the ak as the go-to rifle
would be to upset the very order of
counter-strike
to destabilize a universal balance that
had taken almost
two decades to achieve capitalizes but
they have to deal with drops and he is
ridiculous with his ak looking for the
one versus once he finds the one
he can get and he kills it there it is
so he has to get the reload in somebody
is now elevated drops he makes it work
robs with three and that's gonna be
mount sports with the
well the first round of overtime that's
unreal i thought i think we all fought
they had no chance but they turn it
around
and then about midway through 2019
that's
exactly what happened and it ruined
counter-strike
i'm gonna be into the retake scenario
for atk
oh okay and a decent fade away shot to
start jk
he's back once again four kills you just
got everyone in a matter of seconds
the creek is ridiculous right now um
it's just it's too strong for the price
and
the power it holds you can take duels
with an op
or you just feel so confident holding a
creek in your hand so
i mean yeah it needs to either price
that needs to be increased or
some kind of other nerf to it but yeah
it's really unfair right now i should be
able to take care of these no problem
flash is decent
and taco that will get absolutely
everyone he gets the
3k spray with the creek the sg553
better known by its sore shorthand the
krieg is a scoped assault rifle which
after
years of being underutilized received a
buff in the fall of 2018 that
transformed it
into what was shy of the r8 the single
most
busted gun in the history of cs go
what's the most overpowered gun at the
moment
greg did i have to say anything else
in addition to being only 50 more
expensive than the ak it boasted
all of its benefits zero if its
downsides
and then some it had a scope a faster
rate of fire
and better first shot accuracy than the
op
first bullet accuracy is just 100 all
the time
if you're aiming at the head it's
hitting the head if you aim at the head
with the ak there's a chance it misses
so
why not use the creek shots
what could have caught that
the ak made it so that the t's had
better weapons than the cts which
was fair since the onus was on the tease
to take a sight
with the krieg any semblance of balance
had been abandoned
the cts weren't just being outgunned
they didn't stand a chance
they don't have a lot of grenades on g2
here but when they go it's gonna be fast
then oh they just line up for an
art with a big triple all of them
headshots
however if and when the cts managed to
get their hands on the krieg
there was very very little the teas
could do to overpower
them it comes with great risk is it
worth it at a point where you are two
rounds away from victory
oh maybe it doesn't matter mayon showing
his prowess to taps with the creed
he's looking for one of the most brutal
aces that we've seen in recent memory
that looks so easy 24-16 oh my god the
nerf is coming boys
what's more the rosters who'd been quick
to identify just how
overpowered the krieg actually was
dominated with it
furia its so-called discoverers used it
to pioneer
an absurdly aggressive playstyle that
skyrocketed them into the upper echelon
of competitive cs go
we could have abused it way before even
like got to
through major playoffs with that because
vinnie was playing the creek from all
the way
back to 2016 2017 that was way
earlier before everybody else and when
we started it was just me vinnie
and sometimes casareto and just way
after yuri and right after yuri able
started so it was
just very slowly process of adaptation
to that new meta
freya will try to capitalize on this by
making a place towards the ramp are they
brave enough to go through that smoke
our picks the right direction he's
surrounded by two more players that's a
huge headshot from him
we make funny jokes because if he if he
knew attack rigo as
us uh that strong before we could we
could have been like a
major winners way before because we're
just too strong and we don't even
knew it not to mention the fact that the
truly great riflers the ones who'd
already been gods with the ak became
literal turrets as soon as they set
their
hands on the krieg elige arguably the
best sprayer alive was quick to follow
furious lead which led to liquid
becoming
the world power for much of 2019. i
smoke as well we get that down in 50
seconds you know
they got to reconsider their options
here and at least he actually pushes
through the middle smoke there they had
their grenades out he heard the pins
pulled
and he's going to take the fight man
just finds him astralis with 14 seconds
left they've got a chance to change it
is a legion all the liege started with a
spectacular timing on two
and an ace bk this drop they could be in
serious trouble
that should do it there we go it's team
liquid
and that's what it means to them they've
taken it at the fourth map
the favorites coming into the tournament
have just unlocked the intel grand slam
at esl one cologne underneath and a
million dollars bonus
the ak had been wiped off the face of
the server
everybody from analysts to competitors
to the community at
large began begging valve to do
something
anything to nerf this absolute
abomination
since without the ak counter-strike just
wasn't counter-strike krieg ops
hey i've recently just started like
fully adapting to it now i was i was
sticking to the ak for a little bit
after using it for a little bit now i'm
loving my photo just running around
sorry but um yeah it's pretty op then
let's just say that when the nerf
finally came in april of 2020
riflers everywhere rejoiced
okay let me hear this loud how [ __ ] it
is how slow it shoots
i love it
more importantly it gave counter-strike
stands everywhere a newfound
appreciation for what made the ak so
special to begin with
the fact that it wasn't perfect the fact
that
god tier as it was you actually had to
master it to murk people
as possible he has the best chance to
set the crossfire to find guardian or
does he because
oh my god damn right that is old school
as well what a stray
because at the end of the day that's the
thing that makes the ak
such a work of art it's unwieldiness the
fact that it is a buckwild
beast that boasts one of the steepest
learning curves in esports
with the right pokey and also behind you
and everywhere
yep yep wow that's a lot of um spray
but it also rewards those who've poured
thousands of
hours into taming it flash is right
there as the tag
will have to turn around three times and
eventually
my god three to win the round to tie it
up at 23 to 23
and keep cloud9 alive in many ways the
ak-47 is the epitome of counter-strike
the one weapon in which every mechanic
is perfectly encapsulated
whose mastery amounts to a conversance
with the franchise as a whole
he's gonna have to do even better than
that to try and just
do something for his team it's gonna be
whoa you
run right into it the spray control from
electronic there and a quad kill
it's inspired clones knockoffs and
spiritual successors but
none have ever stepped up to the throne
the ak
is was and always will be the benchmark
for
greatness and tactical first-person
shooters is it
odd that it's never seen a substantial
change
and that we've been shooting the same
rifle for 20 years
maybe but does that mean it's due for
one
no changing it in any way would unravel
the very fabric
of counter-strike and who the hell would
want that
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our instagram
twitter and facebook pages
you